le cantal la corse ce week end voisins
le bretonneux jouer la carte du terroir
produits du cru mais pas seulement
au détour d'un étal une madeleine
inspiré par le célèbre ouvrage à la
recherche du temps perdu
cette madeleine bien d'illiers combray
qui est un village qui se situe pas très
loin de chartres en eure et loir là où
allait marcel proust lors de son enfance
il allé chez sa tante léonie déguster
les fameuses madeleine et donc notre
défi que nous avons relevé avec ma femme
maxime boucher qui a travaillé aux côtés
d'alain passard et camille l'essec qui
était chef pâtissier d'un grand
restaurant parisien 30 hôtel parisien
on a décidé de faire une excellente
plein qui soit à la hauteur de l'oeuvre
de marcel proust
et puis une musique d'un autre temps se
faisait entendre avec les regrattiers
d'histoire vous plonger dans un camp du
xvème siècle c'est un camp ouvert
c'est-à-dire qu'il permet aux gens de
venir à l'intérieur et d'observer de
manipuler donc on l'est on peut très
bien venir toucher essayer les épées
essayer les casques s'initie un petit
peu avec la cuisine médiévale venir
écouter notre chanteuse et harpiste
le marché du week-end du terroir a fermé
ses portes ce dimanche
en attendant la 11e édition